bonjour katia le traditionnel compte
rendu du conseil des ministres par le
porte parole du gouvernement a été
supprimée aujourd'hui c'est donc le
premier ministre lui-même qui s'est
exprimé oui absolument jean castex a
évoqué un projet de loi relatif à la
sortie de crise sanitaire il propose
donc un régime transitoire de sortie de
crise courant du 2 juin au 31 octobre
qui sera soumis au vote du parlement
il permettra d'accompagner en processus
de réouverture au cas où évidemment la
situation sanitaire s'améliorait mais il
proposera également des outils
en cas de rebond épidémique à savoir qu
emmanuel macron présentera vendredi des
perspectives de déconfinement pourquoi
aussi revenu sur le projet de loi
antiterroriste présenté ce matin en
conseil des ministres
oui exactement ce projet de loi prévoit
un renforcement des moyens humains pour
accompagner la surveillance de
potentiels terroristes et il vise à
s'adapter aux nouvelles menaces à
utiliser les nouvelles technologies
technologies qui font parfois débat
alors gérald darmanin rappeler que 36
attentats avaient été commis depuis 2010
est ce projet de loi comporte 19
articles qui vise à pérenniser ou
compléter des lois expérimental de la
loi citée de la loire ans loi du
renseignement de 2015 par exemple le
traitement automatisé des données
téléphoniques de messagerie ou de
connexions sur des sites 1 par des
algorithmes
alors il faut selon gérald darmanin
adapté des méthodes de surveillance qui
existe déjà pour la téléphonie aux
données aux traces numériques
car aujourd'hui la menace endogène est
plus difficile à suivre
cette loi permettra également de
renforcer le suivi et le contrôle des
terroristes qui sortent de détention
après cinq ans de peine ou trois en cas
de récidive et l'a7
eric dupond moretti qui a expliqué à ces
nouvelles mesures
il a évoqué des mesures de réinsertion
sociale avec une prise en charge
sanitaire psychologique par exemple des
humbles et des interdictions de se
déplacer ou des obligations à travailler
sans quoi l'ancien détenu devra
retourner en prison
voilà ce qu'on peut retenir de cette
conférence de presse qui s'est achevé il
y à peu merci beaucoup katia technique
pour toutes ces précisions